foreign
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
146 qna segment with dog
barely barely visible there she is there
she is all right sweepy
as if On Cue as if very nice yeah she's
not gonna want to keep her head up
though no she
um hello friend
okay here we go uh we're going to start
with the question that came out of the
Discord server this week where they vote
on a question every week that we do a q
a and uh we get asked to answer the top
voted question this week it is
institutionalized science appears to be
excluding or suppressing alternate
findings at an alarming rate from covet
issues to Pharma in general even to the
science of archeology and quote the
Bering land bridge in every single case
there are a set of Institutions that
profit from holding onto the cherished
we need empirical methods to call out
behaviors as they happen
is it possible
we need so that's sentence
the tricky one we need empirical methods
to call out behaviors as they happen so
I worry about two things one I worry
that I'm not exactly sure what that
means obviously the ability to call out
errors in real time has a value it also
you know I think we've talked earlier on
previous podcasts
about
the fact that science at The Cutting
Edge is very very noisy inherently yeah
and so in some sense the problem is that
the public thinks that science that is
to say the things that we have learned
over you know decades centuries
Millennia uh is the same thing as the
active process that you can read it as
it comes off the the press and it's the
same deal and it's just not so what I
don't want is people freaking out over
natural normal sorting processes you
know there's something there there's
something really important there where
there's this job description or this is
job title science journalist and what
people seem to think that means is a
journalist who covers science
and actually the methods of Journalism
and the methods of science are different
enough the way in which Discovery
happens in journalism and happens in
science are different enough that you
can't just be like well I used to study
I used to do journalism on sports or you
know politics and now I do science like
you actually have to consider
differently about what the underlying
reality is and what it means yes and
you're I don't want to say training
because I completely leave open the
possibility of being self-trained in
this regard but yeah you can't if you
report if you just get put on the
science beat
you don't know enough you don't have any
idea where the bodies are buried right
and so when I look at a science
journalist I want somebody who knows
where the bodies are buried and can
therefore navigate it critically and
what we what we have is people who are
basically parroting the equivalent of
press releases
they're in no position to uh
play any sort of a watchdog role right
they just simply report the portrayal
that the scientists themselves or the
agencies or whatever are putting in the
world and so that's a very bad thing but
what I don't want is the idea that oh
the solution to this is to have you know
a watchdog that you know parses every
sentence and figures out whether or not
it stands up to the whatever standard
because that doesn't work either yep yep
um so that's one thing I had a second
objection what was it let me read the
quote again yeah excuse me
institutionalized science appears to be
excluding or suppressing alternate
findings at an alarming rate from covet
issues to Pharma in general even to the
science of archeology and the bearing
land bridge in every single case there
are a set of Institutions that profit
from holding on to the cherished we need
empirical methods to call it behaviors
as they happen is it possible
yeah okay then my other concern is this
is a classic case of the liberal
solution maker oh my goodness wow all
right the liberal solution maker that
doesn't see
all right Maddie you're making it very
hard people to take them seriously and
some of them are having it look how she
was all cuddled up against you your
pants are blonde to prove it I know she
comes over to my side to like sneeze on
the computer
part seems perfectly reasonable to me
but all right
so here here's the problem right you see
it's
this is not going well okay all right
you see the failure
and you think I know that failure
wouldn't be happening if not for X I'll
fix X yeah and you don't realize that
you've just opened the door to some
potentially even worse failure and so my
point would be look we have a failure in
which what we are fed as the scientific
truth is garbage it is often
motivated by profiteering or
political concerns or whatever it's just
not science right the solution to that
could be monitoring it and making sure
that what passes for science is actually
scientific but the problem is once you
build that system and you call it you
know the Watchdog system then the
question is well how can that Watchdog
system be used to suppress
truths that are inconvenient for other
reasons and so I I worry that the abuses
of the system that you're proposing are
actually worse than the thing that
you're curing and believe me I don't
think the thing you're curing is minor I
think it's terrifying and so the idea
that you may be inviting an even worse
problem is is worth considering yeah and
I guess one more thing
uh is the the reality that
some of what we think is true is true
and some of what we think is true is not
true and we need systems and I have
written about this specifically in my
essay on College presidents um with
regard to higher ed
Wade systems which simultaneously
protect Orthodoxy and are open to
heterodoxy and so you know allow
researchers who are doing you know what
I call Brick and the wall science to do
their Brick in the Wall science which
builds scientific uh knowledge one brick
at a time on a foundation that hopefully
is apt and true but may not be but also
allows and encourages and facilitates
those scientists who are doing you know
breakthrough style science theoretical
scientists you know people who risk
pointing out actually that Foundation
that all your bricks are built on is
faulty none of that is true
so you you actually do need a system
that does both things simultaneously and
this is you know this is the job of a
college President uh but it's it also
needs to be the job of a number of other
sort of Arbiters of systems and I don't
I don't know I don't know what that
looks like
um but you know focusing on the call out
the behavior as it happens is only
thinking about one side of the issue
that you we we actually you know there
there is a role for presumably hopefully
most of which we most of what we think
is true is true right and so
um part of what we're seeing
with the woke stuff with that ideology
is a like throw it all out approach like
you know there there are problems with
the system as it exists for sure with
regard to what the the Websters are
pointing out but they would have us
throw out a whole bunch of functional
functional work along with the the
pieces that aren't and
um that is the sort of the opposite
error
so I'm in a conversation with Steve
Patterson in which he recently said
um philosophy is where it's at
philosophers aren't
which resonated for me immediately
because I think you and I both take
philosophy especially philosophy of
science very seriously
um because we know how much it matters
we've seen that
um but I am
struck
weekly by the absence of philosophers of
science talking about all of the
violations of
uh fundamental scientific principles
that are being paraded in front of us
right as if they don't exist when you
said that I was like wait
do we have any philosophers for science
we haven't heard anything from any of
them have we we have hundreds of them
and the point is they misunderstand
their job they do not understand that
their job is not to talk to other
philosophers of science right their job
is to talk about science so that we can
make sure the process runs and it's a
very delicate process it's very powerful
but it's very delicate likewise
I would say historians of science are
busy doing something pointless when in
fact what they should be doing is
telling us how this actually works in
places where we've come to understand
something right what did it look like as
we started to understand it what you
know what yes junk crept in with the big
insight and how long did it persist and
what is it that caused it
um to finally be discovered you know so
worthy such a worthy Endeavor and where
is it
science historians and science
philosophy philosophers are science and
historians of science are doing
different things which are too often
conflated with one another yep but
historian of science it seems to me uh
is ought to be engaged more in in peer
description of what transpired and the
philosopher of philosophy of science
ought to be engaged in describing how
how scientific discovery uh occurs and
and you know what constitutes uh
evidence and what causes a hypothesis
and whether or not you know when
prediction you know when predictions
could be ignored Etc
um and I would add to that list
how does science function differently
with respect to complexity as it does
with respect to fundamentals this is one
of the places that we screw up science
because we think we know how science
Works based on what worked in the early
days of physics and chemistry and we
don't understand the complexity uh
upends some of those that those were
approximations also even the scientific
method itself is instantiated
approximately
yep
okay I lost my thread because of the
chaos happening here
um I think this is a critical question
that
I at least I haven't heard from you
don't have the solution at the like what
system needs to be put into place level
but what we can do is describe and I
think have tried to do here is describe
ways in which you could make an error in
trying to describe the solution to
Simply unless create the opposite
problem well so I will go one step
further then I think
the solution does not exist at the level
proposed here
that what you need is something and it's
going to be institutional level that is
capable of restructuring the incentives
of individuals so that being right
actually ends up putting you ahead
yeah and the problem is that we have a
system in which being wrong puts you
ahead and being right will often get you
thrown out and unless you have an
institution that's capable of basically
taking some long period of time and
saying the objective is to get
increasingly correct over that period
not to look increasingly correct this
afternoon when you know your paper comes
out in nature
right
um that that's the key that's the
solution really if you fix the
incentives so that the individual could
not get ahead by being wrong you don't
have to do anything else and that's the
hard part
okay we're going to take a short break
we're not going to go off air because we
can't do that to um encourage the dog to
come back this is a strange little
situation we got here and she doesn't
know that she can make it up even though
she just made it down come on up yeah
there's a little there's a step see yep
step C come on you can do it yeah I'll
let you know something about Captain the
cat yes
we'll know the cat the other cat is
considering eating himself eaten by a
deer
nice okay
all right there we go oh God she's gonna
sit on my computer okay hello
friend all right yes
okay let's go into the questions at
darker submissions.com now
and you are welcome to ask questions
there uh dark horsemissions.com
first question if I wanted to undermine
both the judeo-christian ethos and
Western Scientific understanding of
evolutionary biology I would focus my
attack on our understanding of
biological sex
if God created them male and female and
you succeed in Breaking the male female
Paradigm you break the system
that's interesting it's kind of a twofer
so a really good point yeah yeah it's
it and and so bold like
if I had wanted to break the system
and I was looking for ways to do it and
I had happened upon this even if I'd
seen the two for quality of it as this
person does with regard to both
judeo-christian and and biological
reality
I would have given it up for
like being an impossibility how could
how could you possibly like if you can
convince people that there aren't two
Sexes that male and female aren't quite
real that men get pregnant Etc
well then
it's over like like that if you can give
in some of that you can convince them of
anything and until now I didn't actually
think that you can convince people of
anything yeah I agree I guess like I'm
that I was that naive it's an audacious
attack incredible what I what I like
about this proposal
is that so the thing that uh Robert
Wright
seems to think uh I'm nuts over
is the sense that something is uh
wrecking our system that begins not to
be explainable through simple
incompetence it's too too many failures
to directly targeted of things that are
essential to the functioning of our
system like military Readiness and
anyway the point
the point is if you imagine if you allow
yourself to imagine that something is
trying to mess up function rather than
we are simply failing to fix the leaks
or whatever then you come up with
something like this and you say okay
here's one if you could nail this one
you get both our scientific
comprehension at The evolutionary level
and uh our religious understanding of
who we are and what we mean you break
two of our most significant
very likely I think actually our two
most significant sources of meaning and
meaning making apparatuses in the modern
world yep
um so the point is
could be a coincidence but it's
certainly interesting that that
particular uh failure which you know any
reasonable person can see just so
happens to Target two systems directly
that we typically don't think of in the
same breath yeah
I think this is apt and insightful and
important yeah
next question
there seems to be a thought pattern that
we need to suspend freedoms to save
democracy and compromise health and
safety standards to keep everyone
healthy and safe
does this logical fallacy have a name or
a precedent
and again you guys are on fire today
that's just that is so perfectly
formulated
um it's not exactly the big lie but it's
related to it right the idea and
there's something about
the Catch-22 nature of things that the
point is the Paradox needs to be exactly
symmetrical in order for it to work
somehow the closer it is to saying
something that is perfectly impossible
the more effective it is
um you know it feels I mean it's not a
catch-22 but it feels more like a
catch-22 than the big lie the big lie
strikes me as we're going to say
something so Preposterous that you can't
possibly imagine we'd be lying about
something this big but it's content free
right the big lie has says nothing at
all about content whereas this
observation is in order to save X you
need to destroy X first in order to save
y first you need to go after y like it's
it's fair it's it is it is content
um neutral with regard to like it could
be any X or any y presumably but it is
content specific in that in order to
save X you need to First go after X like
there has to be an X there whereas the
big lie doesn't doesn't did that at all
I don't feel like that's that's this
um Catch 22 gets a little closer
um but not quite and I'm trying to think
I imagine I don't know if you're looking
at the chat Zack if anyone comes up with
anything
so uh
I like the we had to destroy X to save X
so it's sort of like the melee well
that's what that's what she the question
asker has said we need to suspend
freedoms to save democracy in we need to
compromise health and safety standards
to keep everyone healthy and safe
yes we need to destroy military
Readiness in order to make ourselves
militarily ready we need to get students
to uh submit to a an indefensible
medical interpretation of the fact in
order that they can learn how to
interpret facts right I mean you know
yeah it is this in every case and
it is causing
a
what I think for many of us is a
mind-boggling Schism because for some of
us if you say you know the reason we
compromise military Readiness was to
make ourselves militarily ready
it's like well I don't know what area
you're making but I can tell that that's
[ __ ] right and if you if you look at
the excuse and you say and say sort of
you know
that's happening over here and then over
in this different part of the play
you're like okay that thing that you're
doing
is that going to enhance military
Readiness or compromise and maybe you
can't get there in one step maybe it
takes five steps to get there but if you
can like if if the thing that has been
implemented
can be agreed on by the people who are
doing it to yes have the effect of for
instance uh decreasing military
Readiness then you can take that and
move it back in here and say okay then
if you know if if
l22 whatever it is that you were calling
it equals X
and we recognize that the system is
there to enhance X and l22 that you've
just implemented which equals x
decreases X then decreasing X can't
increase X all right that was that was
cloogy but I think it holds
let's try this first of all I will say
this was the topic I talked in Arizona
about was how could Orwell have been
this right right as I've said on Dark
Horse before the upside downness of the
language seems too extreme to be real
and yet
we are living in an era in which the
language has been turned that upside
down so what if the point is
if something were to get into your
system
with the intent of
getting you to wreck it yourself your
bigger system not an individual bodily
system yeah okay
um
I mean frankly it might work but that's
right but I'm talking about our
social systems
um that effectively what it would do is
it would send a divide by zero message
mm-hmm right you would get in and it
would tell you to divide by zero which
frankly if you go back to our response
to being demonetized by YouTube We asked
YouTube to divide by zero because
frankly YouTube is illegitimate if it
decides to manage what we can and cannot
say in a way that is bad for us
um
but you could imagine something getting
into your system and trying to get you
know if you set x equal to 1 over X
right right then
you create a situation where but how do
you I mean the thing that we keep on
arriving back at in Mass psychosis is
one possible one answer in at least a
partial answer but like
how do you get people to accept how is
it that so many people have accepted
that x equals 1 over X well that's you
know that's actually one possible
framing for like you know does this
logical fallacy have a name or president
like if it doesn't a name for it might
be the x equals 1 over X fallacy okay
but this does have a
well studied that doesn't work because X
could be one
there are X's for which it can work yeah
but the point is you can't set it that
way as a policy right um but you know
the point is it doesn't make sense in
math it makes sense in programming you
can tell a computer to do this
you can't assert that it's true right
right um right okay good distinction but
uh
the problem is we know more or less in
fact I would say we know very well how
you get people to accept
um transparently false syllogisms
and the way you do it is making the cost
of not accepting it so high that
um
acceptance is the only rational thing to
do from the perspective of well-being
which is what that's one of the ways
another way is that you prime them
you inform them in advance about how
awesome thing X is
and then when thing y comes in dressed
as an X you say look at this brand new X
and when some people's like that's a why
that's not an X at all like come on
don't you love X right you wouldn't want
to be one of those anti-exers no no you
certainly wouldn't no
um so that's true but I I think that
still fits the Paradigm if we if we if
we map
anti-vaxxers onto what you just said
right
we all know that vaccines are a
fantastic mechanism for limiting the
spread of contagious diseases right then
you introduce something and you ensure
that the terminology used for it is
vaccine and then anybody who says hey
wait a minute that's not a good idea it
doesn't matter biologist or not the
point is oh didn't know you were an
anti-vaxxer right but the point is when
when they say anti-vax or what they're
doing is they're threatening you as we
explored in an earlier episode there's a
buzz saw with anti-vaxxer on the label
yep and if you come anywhere near
questioning anything that comes through
a syringe you get shoved into it yeah so
presumably lots of Precedence that we
can Discover it seems like they're all
coming right now there's so many coming
right now that it's extraordinary I'm
curious if I feel like every logical
fallacy that can't that can be made has
been named and I many often I feel like
people wield the names of the fallacies
without knowing what they are and they
think they're educated as a result so I
honest I don't know the names of most
the fallacies as a result because I find
it a silly way to demonstrate knowledge
um but I am curious if this one does
have a name I assume it does but I like
at least for now the stand-in of the x
equals 1 over X fallacy
okay which it's it it sounds said that
way it sounds absurd and yet it is
exactly that absurd and that's why I
like I very much like the way that she
has and I'm just going to read it once
more there seems to be a writes it which
is that there seems to be a thought
pattern that we need to suspend freedoms
to save democracy and compromise health
and safety standards to keep everyone
healthy and safe
yeah excellent love this question
okay next question
so many threats from so many different
directions social forces national state
and party level even International
Trends what are your thoughts on where
to best focus our energy deepest
respects
um I mean I I think it's actually a
simpler puzzle than we think because
what we see is a zillion failures
um but
you've got
Game Theory problems like the one we
just discovered or discussed
um
and you have an the thing about these
Collective action problems right if we
all stand up they can't come after all
of us yes but if you stand up because if
we all do it they can't come after us
they can come after you so you won't
stand up so nobody stands up so we get
slaughtered right so the point is look
logically speaking
that is a very easy problem to solve
practically speaking it's an almost
impossible problem to solve and the
reason is because you have to have a
coordination entity that is capable of
structuring the incentives
to move us in the right Collective
Direction and something has
systematically unhooked the institutions
that are large enough and oriented in a
way that they could do it and so the
problem is we keep running up against
the same mind numbing Collective action
problem that we can't solve not because
we don't know the solution but because
we don't have the thing big enough
to do the job
yes
yes so institutions are the answer
in my personal opinion our institutions
are so far gone they can't be rescued
um that could be wrong I would like it
to be wrong I mean I agree with what you
just said I don't think it answers the
question I don't have an answer to the
question
uh but the question is given that there
are so many threats from all these
different directions what are your
thoughts on where to best focus our
energy and the r there I think suggests
individuals who are trying to make
decisions about what what do you do
right and I but before we go back to
that one of the things I was thinking
about
um
as you were talking is that uh to some
degree what we're doing uh here at dark
horse is precisely giving people things
to share so that you know we
we lost our jobs as professors and we're
we're
no longer teaching explicitly
evolutionary biology in the same way
although our book does a fair bit of
that
um but we are able to have a much larger
audience and that allows people who are
looking at this going like oh I feel
like I'm in a ransom situation I want to
stand up but I don't know if anyone else
is going to stand up and it's like I've
got you know you've got the girl and
I've got the money and oh my God I don't
want you to end up with both and so you
know no one stands up it's like well to
some degree what what we're doing
especially with the clips that
um are are awesome other producer puts
out
it's like here share that maybe maybe
that's the thing that you know the
degree to which you have stood up by
passing that along to your uncle or your
boyfriend or you know your work
colleague is saying yes I am vouching
for this enough that I think that you
might be interested you know and maybe
it's just like a shot across the bow
like it could be any number of things it
could be like do you see what I see or
hey
the dog just dream kicked me in the ribs
dude not cool
and um
like there are a number of reasons that
people might share
um share these things but it can be sort
of an opening for a way for people to
have the confidence
that and it like there's a lot of
reasons to to not do it like people are
losing their jobs people are losing
their families people are losing all
sorts of things but having these sorts
of of nuggets that you can share does
help a little bit with that game theory
problem but again but well that was
there's another interpretation of
um what role we're playing and actually
why we end up being a thorn in the side
of oh I think there's a lot that's just
one tiny piece that there's that's
hardly I hardly brought that I know it's
not exhaustive production but
what I hear from people what I know you
hear from people a lot is the you're
keeping us sane
which
I take as an indication
we've talked about the difference
between terms of Art and jargon terms of
art are unaffordable unavoidable
complexities of language that are
necessary to do work in a given field
jargon is something used to keep people
out so they don't know what you're
talking about right keep people out of
your lane yeah keep people out of your
lane to complexify things unnecessarily
so that nobody can enter right what you
and I are doing is demystifying this
landscape right we've trained so that we
can understand what the jargon is
covering and then saying actually this
isn't that complex here's what you need
to know and therefore your intuition
that this thing that you're being you
know take let's take the following one
you've just been told about these mRNA
inoculations and you've been told that
they are safe and effective
and you think well I know that safety is
established somehow I know I don't know
what that somehow is or how good it is
or anything maybe they are safe and
effective and then you have somebody
kind of say look I don't know if they're
effective but they couldn't possibly be
safe because in order to be safe you
have to know that there's no long-term
risk and they couldn't possibly know
that they're too new you know enough to
know they're not safe that doesn't mean
they're harmful it means we don't know
they're safe no one on earth knows
they're safe right it can't be known
right so the point is demystifying their
claim of safety so that you recognize
actually no
to say that something is safe you know
putting a gun to your head and pulling
the trigger is not safe even if it's
unloaded you don't know if it's unloaded
so that process of demystifying is
um
very useful in emboldening people who
would otherwise be cowed into accepting
wrong stuff because they didn't have the
language or the tools to necessarily
know what that nagging intuition that
something is off was about and so
um
anyway
I do think
I think the punch line of the whole
thing
is this which is actually quite hopeful
we are suffering from the failure of
every institution because a single
institution that functioned would
actually be sufficient
to turn the tide if you had one
newspaper that committed itself to
journalism instead of parroting a
political ideology
then the point is everyone would flock
to it because we are all looking for
that newspaper right so therefore there
must not be one zero is a special number
the number of functional newspapers has
to be zero if there was one University
that functioned to educate students
everybody would send their kids to it
there must not be one right and so the
point is there were Publications who
were doing and I feel like spectator and
unheard and and such are at least making
making the solid attempt they're not
newspaper there are very small examples
of exceptions and what typically happens
to these things over time is they either
are relegated to some small role or they
grow get targeted and and succumb so
anyway the punch line is that's a dire
situation to be in but it also means if
you had one platform if you had one
newspaper if you had one University if
you had one truth-seeking entity of
sufficient size that was not subject to
these Dynamics then it would be in a
position to expose the rest of it and so
you would in effect bootstrap your way
out
and so in what way to focus our efforts
figure out what thing and you know maybe
it's Elon buys Twitter
right maybe that's why we are seeing
so much ink spilled over elon's attempt
to purchase and then his attempt not to
purchase Twitter because it's that
important if Twitter was a place that
you could actually have these
discussions then of course it would be
the only place to have a discussion who
wants to live in a censored environment
where there are certain things that
can't be said that might be vital to
your well-being so the point is your
Twitter becomes a place where you can
say whatever needs to be said then there
is no other social media platform yeah
right only a [ __ ] would go to a
different platform in such an era
foreign
I watched the show with military members
it was fantastic regarding Wright's
criticism my understanding was
discussion was vax mandates having the
effect of reducing military Readiness I
did not hear you say that the Democrats
goal was to reduce military Readiness is
Right making a jump or did I miss
something
well he's making a jump but it's a small
one I did not say the Democrats what I
said was The Blue Team now blue team is
a reference to the various things that
are aligned with the Democratic party
right so I take it that there is
something it's a cabal it has power it
is aligned with the Democratic Party
and it is issuing mandates that are
having the effect of compromising
military readiness
so in what way that happens is the
interesting question and maybe I'm
seeing things that aren't true but I
will let me tell you one tiny little
anecdote
um it is possible to live in a bubble in
which the things that you
seek out reinforce your preconceptions
it's very hard to imagine how that would
happen with Airline seating
I was seated next to a Navy
I won't say too much about them I don't
want to get him in trouble but I was
seated next to an active Navy service
member
career military from a military family
didn't know who I was
and I mentioned to him that I had talked
to these military whistleblowers and
that what they were suggesting was that
these mandates were crippling readiness
and he rolled his eyes and he says they
absolutely are this is somebody who
accepted
these so-called vaccines because he had
no choice in order to hold on to his job
but I talked to him about all of the
ways
that I was coming to understand
Readiness was being compromised right
that we were seeing suicides that we
were seeing uh a a notable decrease in
morale that retention and recruitment is
low right that people are compromised by
injury and are therefore no longer able
to fight that we are sidelining some of
our best Pilots I ran by the whole list
of ways in which our Readiness is
compromised and he you know this was not
somebody who was shy about disagreeing
he was perfectly ready to disagree where
I had something wrong but basically my
understanding that I got from these
military whistleblowers of all the ways
in which our Readiness was being
compromised
reflects this
randomly chosen by the vagaries of
Airlines seating member of the military
that I happen to be sitting next to wow
so the point is I don't think this is
subtle I don't think that's
extraordinary secret I think it's just
happening and so basically what I would
say is look
the full range of possibilities is
narrowed
right we are crippling military
Readiness right we are doing it with
mandates
why
I don't know but
whatever it is that's going on has to
explain why you would [ __ ] military
Readiness in the name of military
readiness
because that's what we're doing right so
x equals 1 over X yeah exactly and you
know my point is okay well that actually
requires a kind of a
powerful explanation right it could be
incompetence but it has to be some
special newfangled gain of function
hyper incompetence right rather than
just normal human levels of incompetence
you know over three years ago when uh
gain of function were three words you
could have put together and been like
huh
remember something about that like Obama
in a function gain of function yeah I I
remember being uh you know
for many years I've been tracking the
catastrophes where you only learn about
the process that's being utilized after
it has gone wrong I'm well aware and I
started saying okay so just to name a
few deep water Horizon in the Gulf of
Mexico
uh credit default swaps on the financial
collapse of 2008 the alizo canyon
disaster in Southern California right
we've got a whole
list of things
where we're doing something some very
dangerous and we list those things
incidentally in our book which was
completely drafted before covet hit yeah
and so anyway gain of function gets
added to the list of things you didn't
know we were doing that you needed to
know we were doing because at the point
it goes wrong everything changes but
it's kind of it's a little bit
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy it's
like well
it was publicly available to anyone who
wanted to know at all times I mean it
was in the basement down the stairs
where the lights are out and the swamp
and the alligators and I believe the
stairs were gone yeah exactly it was
available we wanted to defend your
planet from being obliterated in order
to put together put in a highway then
you just should have gone and looked at
the paperwork right it's really on you
that you didn't know and you know so
it's not on me anymore because I've now
started asking where is the list of
really dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ] that we're
doing that I've never heard of that I'm
Gonna Wanna Have Known about at the
point that goes wrong I feel entitled to
that list and there's no list there's no
list yeah all right well I want to add
something here okay which I forgot to
mention during the main podcast but
struck me as so remarkable that
um it deserves to be in here somewhere
all right
um
a
publication a scientific publication
emerged
that reported an experimental finding in
which if I understood it correctly
the S protein that is the spike protein
Gene from
the Omicron variant
was somehow
grafted into a wild type which I think
means the original Stars cov2 genome
right the Wuhan strain wild type SARS
cov2 is pretty wild wild side I really
we're going to use that term here I hope
I'm not inventing that part but I do
believe they used wild type WT but
anyway the point is
they did this fascinating slash
terrifying experiment in which they took
this
Escape variant
produced Gene for Spike protein and they
put it on the Wuhan strain I think it
was the Wuhan strain
and
then they did some stuff with it where
they gave it to a bunch of myosin 80 of
them died okay now okay
virus that they had created the Franken
Franken virus the Franken squared virus
yeah
considering
it maybe at this point it's hard it's
hard to keep track of the exponents
actually in light of the weirdness
surrounding the Genome of Omicron maybe
it is cubed but anyway we digress the
point is one
that suggests something very frightening
I mean a it could be it's possible that
the mice are weirdly vulnerable and that
that is not in any way indicative of
what would happen in people if such a
thing occurred hi
um
it's like you don't have a computer let
me sit on your lap
um but
let's just say
one
the idea that this new set of genes for
the spike protein which now exist in the
world freely floating around infecting
people
that that combined with
the background from a strain that is
presumably no longer floating around but
certainly could be yeah right it's not
like we did something clever that got
rid of it it just other things out
competed it in the in the Swarm right
there's nothing in what you read that
suggested how difficult this would be to
have happened naturally I think the
point is as an evolutionary biologist I
feel
perfectly well positioned to say
probably not it's not like it's it's
like a person being born with an
elephant trunk or something no I don't
think so I think it's the opposite I
think I think the point is
um a we don't know a ton about how all
this works but a person being infected
with two strains simultaneously
different oh I see too soon right so I
guess I'm not expecting to see this leap
in one go but the the idea that the
whole quadrant the design space involves
a simple taking of two things that were
produced by whatever process got us here
and putting them in the same virus
produces that kind of mortality rate
that's terrifying what is also
terrifying is that somehow in 2022
people are still running experiments oh
my God yep right I mean for one thing
at the very least
these people just handed a tremendously
potentially dangerous formula to
whatever hates us
right
you need a certain amount of biological
knowledge to do what they did but
no but rocket science now a plausible
end product bioweapon is known
yep which takes considerable
technological know-how and money to
build the lab in which to implement that
know-how but but still it exists now
let's just say
I'm not a molecular biologist I'm not a
laboratory scientist hopefully I've
misunderstood something about what I've
read but and I haven't seen I don't need
yeah
um but
the whole thing read as extremely uh
alarming both from the point of view of
what it suggests could evolve
naturally naturally at this point
or what somebody could arrange and the
fact that people are now still playing
these kinds of games in Labs even though
we've seen how you know again a function
experiment that
turned a virus into something with a
comparatively low case fatality rate
still turned the world on its head yeah
yeah right the destruction from this
thing is astronomical and you know will
in the end be indefinitely large given
that we now have no way to control it
yes
yep
I'm inclined to agree with Brett that
being off platform is tantamount to
seating ground being 50 effective review
and five percent is still better than
zero percent force them to ban you then
make a new account wear them down by
attrition
well as somebody with
an account that is apparently incapable
of accumulating new followers according
to the numbers but still has lots and
lots of people following
the problem is if you have an account
that doesn't ever have any followers you
don't have very much
uh capacity to
change the world with it and you don't
have much to lose but you can't reach
for many people or you have the ability
to reach a lot of people and you have a
lot to lose those go hand in hand right
and so what you would need is some
meta platform that would be able to
redirect people at the point that
somebody that you followed
got canceled into Oblivion that could
redirect you but of course because I
mean I think actually Pamela tried that
right and it sounds don't know um I will
say
Twitter expressly forbids this Behavior
oh really yeah
you can't
I mean lots of people have multiple
accounts sure you can have multiple
accounts
but you can't create a new account after
right after you've been told that you
can't have it if you have been thrown
off Twitter you cannot create a new
account and come back on Twitter
if you had five accounts and one of them
got thrown off Twitter
these people have memorized the terms of
service these people make up the rules
as they go along and basically if
somebody they like does it I'm sure it's
fine if somebody they don't like does it
it's probably a capital crime I don't
know yeah yeah
have I mentioned that these people suck
and that the terms of service are
unfollowable deliberately
at points yes you have
um what is this is not the question but
the question begins with agw three
letter acronym
um
Zach's looking it up
uh the question is yes agw is a 1.2
homogenic global warming oh yeah
anthrogenic global warming is a 1.2
trillion dollar industry that much money
how difficult is it to manufacture a
crisis
foreign
well it didn't it didn't start out with
all that money so
I mean it's it was there wasn't 1.2
trillion dollars sitting around waiting
for a crisis to be manufactured right so
the the timing there's a little off but
the question is still apt yep given that
there's that much money were we to
discover that there's no problem would
we be able to talk about it probably not
um now yeah so so rather than
manufacture a crisis uh maintain
manufacture or uh distort
you know exaggerate yeah I mean again
what we have said repeatedly
is there are things you can use that do
not involve these models that the models
are suspect anybody who has worked in
the realm of models knows why they're
suspect it's too easy to generate a
model that will spit out any behavior
that you want
um
and the Dynamics inside these fields are
such that you know look you will be
rewarded for saying things that flatter
the conventional with time wisdom inside
of
modern climatology you will be punished
for saying anything that casts any doubt
on it so anyway there's no way that
these things aren't terrifically messed
up however
there are ways that you as a member of
the public without resorting to models
can figure out where we are what you
can't figure out is where we are
relative to dangerous thresholds right
if the class rate gun hypothesis is
right then the point is we could go from
where we are presently to some dire
situation very quickly and we wouldn't
necessarily know that we had crossed
that threshold but
as I've said repeatedly I was promised
an ice-free Arctic by now
the Arctic isn't ice free I was promised
that there would be no snows left on
Kilimanjaro
there are still glaciers on Kilimanjaro
I was promised that Glacier National
Park would have no glaciers there are
still glaciers there so and I was also
led to believe that sea level would have
risen
significantly and the fact is I look at
the sea from all of the places that I've
visited the Seas a person across my life
so far I don't see it so does that mean
that there's no crisis no because of the
threshold potential but does it mean
that something is acting in an alarmist
fashion relative to realities that I can
check myself
certainly seems so so you know I don't
want anybody to feel comfortable about
this issue because I think at best what
you can say is we are left by a corrupt
scientific system with too little
information to know how much danger
we're in right that does not mean that
we are safe
but
that seems like more or less Where We
Are indeed
okay a follow-up uh to the question uh
from
that asked about the vaccine mandates
and Robert Wright thank you but the
point of my question is about the
intentionality the causality versus
correlation is it clear that reduction
in Readiness is a state of is a side
effect of vax mandates
wait no
this is okay let me try again it's
Punctuation is missing thank you but the
point of my question is about the
intentionality parentheses causality and
correlation it is clear that reduction
in Readiness is a side effect of vax
mandates it is not clear that this is
the intention of the blue team but
rather a knock-on effect of their agenda
that they are willing to tolerate
well the thing that Robert Wright took
me to task for was noting that the
mandates are in retreat in the civilian
world and that they are maintained in
the military World despite the impact on
Military Readiness which is easily
observed so the question is but there's
a third population what what about other
government workers who weren't in the
military if the mandates aren't being
reduced
if if the minutes are just like in place
in the government they're not and not in
place they're not they're being dropped
for both Federal and it doesn't matter
State I guess right because they're
being maintained in the military where
their effect is arguably worst right
okay and so the question is look the dod
ought to be obsessed with military
Readiness right a this is a
long-standing conversation we have a
standard we are supposed to maintain we
are supposed to be able to fight and win
two simultaneous Wars that's how ready
we're supposed to be
Readiness is not a vague concept right
it is a concrete concept to the extent
that these mandates might initially have
been deployed in the hope that they
would protect this force from a disease
that turned out not to be as dangerous
as we thought and certainly is not as
dangerous to young people in the
military who are in general healthier
than the rest of the population right it
could be that they screwed up at first
but then given the importance of
Readiness you would certainly expect
that on discovering the impact on
Readiness that there would be a rapid
change in the policy so as not to do any
more damage than we had already done
instead what we see is the preservation
of the policy with respect to the
military where it's in Retreat elsewhere
so it doesn't say anything about intent
um except it leaves us with a question
we have to answer which is why why would
we make this error of all errors
how long we've been at it Zack
let's do a few more
I'm not sure what this is a response to
but I like the sentiment you don't have
to be rich to afford a subscription to
join the Discord and discuss why it's
right to jump into the fight with a pen
though instead of a sword
foreign
frankly they're not mutually exclusive
I mean most people are not ambidextrous
though so you kind of need to choose
what you put in your dominant hand
no that's why you have a sheath
you can't use them both at the same time
then true
but you can have them both at the ready
depending upon what kind of situation
you end up in
I'm just saying it's good to be prepared
no I'm trying to figure out which
questions to all right answer
um they're all good and we don't have a
ton of time oh here
from Echo did the evolution of
synchronized male female orgasm in
humans Drive The Evolution of Music and
of tone in language
much love to you too
wow my instinct on this is totally no
but it's a cool idea
you know there's
um
I used to
in my lectures on sexual selection and
mating systems and such I I used to use
a video
of a pair-bonded pair of I can't
remember what species of birds do
wedding
and you couldn't
like it was very very hard and I if I
remember correctly in Parts you really
couldn't tell which one of them was
singing at a particular time they it
sounded like it just it was so perfect
and so this just reminds me that there's
there's synchronization
and I don't know I don't know what the
state of orgasmism birds they're looked
into it no idea I think you know they
have the cloak kiss they don't even have
an intermittent organ it's very brief I
doubt I I don't even know I have no idea
I have no idea
um but synchronization in Birds uh at
least in songbirds and pair-bonded
Songbird songbirds being an actual like
lineage of passerines
um giant lineage of birds most of the
birds giant lineage of non-giant birds
mostly non-giant Birds indeed
um
synchronicity
is part of what drives or or enhances at
least the pair bond in the monogamy so I
think she has she's onto something with
regard to
um pair bonding and synchronous behavior
and synchronous pleasure
but I don't think that synchronous
orgasm leading to music or leading to
what was it tone and language
necessarily I think that's I don't think
you need to go there and I don't know if
it's a bridge too far exactly but it
affects me it's like not quite the right
timing I think you've got it again just
because the primate part of this
um
as you know many years ago during
prelims as a graduate student I did a
paper a review paper
on uh
monogamy and primates and
what you just tried it out
it what it revealed one of the patterns
that shocked me was that every single
known instance of a monogamous primate
species at that point
exhibited duetting Behavior all right so
this is going to be Gibbons including
the siming uh microcephus mouse lemur
mouse lemur was not understood to be
okay monogamous teeny
monkeys would twine their tails yeah
um it was
um certain characters no not Orange
yeah right of course so some Marvis had
some tamarinds right yeah but anyway the
point being we know that the synchrony
that Echo is pointing to here actually
as I mean maybe there's something about
orgasm in all these species that we
don't know but in primates maybe given
that the duetting precedes the do
wedding accompanies the monogamy and
apparently has for quite some time
because of the ancientness of the sum
total group in which we see this
Behavior it probably doesn't have
anything to do with uh simultaneous
orgasm which is presumably a human thing
so
probably not
there is a lot on this topic that would
be
um
worth delving into deeply in other words
one of one of the things I
um
I want to explore is
given all the things we've talked about
that have [ __ ] up the sexual landscape
the question is well what did it look
like
before those things impinged on it right
and I don't think we have a good
understanding of that and it it would be
it would be very useful to do it so
we've got like a cartoon version of that
history yeah exactly
okay let's do uh one one more
um
before we sign off for a couple weeks
why does motion sickness cause nausea
what do movement and balance have to do
with expelling toxins is it the shifting
stomach acids nope yeah nope
um you wanna you can start all right the
traditional explanation which I gotta
say often I don't find these things
compelling but this one I do
is that your
um
perception
of your
I don't know what to call it I'm
struggling is proprioception gonna be
the right term here in any case your
perceptual apparatus that figures out
how to hold your head steady so I think
there may be another word but
proprioception is it's related yeah but
the thing you know in order to track
visually as you're walking let's say you
have to hold your head reasonably steady
and correct for the movement of things
right
if you ingest a poison let's say that
you ingest too much alcohol
then you are unable to coordinate that
which would need to be coordinated to
keep your visual apparatus steady and so
the point is a symptom of the poison is
that your the steadiness of your visual
field is compromised right so I mean
alcohol
think we know about the maximums of
action on of alcohol and nausea and it's
it's fairly precise whereas other toxins
may have a slightly so doesn't alcohol
affect like the oh boy the vestibular
wrapper it's vestibular apparatus like
the hairs it it causes them to to
but fail I don't think I don't think it
matters from this point well I I just
it's just that it's not like a toxin
such as alcohol because alcohol is a
very particular effect that other toxins
may not well let's just say if you took
some sort of a toxin it might leave your
ability to coordinate your head and
stabilize your visual field perfectly
intact but one of the things that some
unnamed toxin might do is interfere with
that right to the extent that it
interferes with your ability to keep
your legs under you your ability to keep
your eyes steady right so the point is
it is very it is comparatively cheap
to puke if you've got evidence that you
might have been poisoned right it is
very expensive to fail to puke if you
have been poisoned and so the point is
why does
drunkenness excessive drunkenness
um
the motion of a boat
rolling down a hill and getting
extremely dizzy why do all of these
things trigger this nauseous nauseous
response and the answer is because
they all produce something that is a
symptom of being poisoned and at that
point although it's not as cheap as it
might be your ancestors were stressed
for food and so puking if you don't have
to isn't great but being poisoned and
holding on to the poison and having to
detoxify it is way worse than getting
rid of everything you know in your
system so
you know rolling down a hill
isn't solved the dizziness that comes
from rolling down a hill isn't solved by
puking but
um but the point is the danger that that
puking is indicating something chemical
uh is great enough that it leaves in
that direction
I don't know how clear that was but I
feel like the connection between these
things is pretty clear
yeah
come back to this question yeah like I
should have lost the lost one of the
three threads
um I think we can we can be even more
clear but but I can't make it more clear
right now
I'm being slight I'm slightly distracted
by the snoring of the dog who finds US
apparently uninteresting very
uninteresting even as we approach dinner
time for the dog which should make us
very interesting yes
um well I think we're there I believe so
I think we're there uh look out for more
uh Dark Horse episodes uh in our absence
we will be back two weeks from yesterday
on what's that going to be just for the
Saturday before Halloween
we'll be back on the
why does my computer thinks it's
currently the
the day that it's not
um
yeah the 29th
thank you and anything else to say
before we sign off I don't think so
certainly there's so much chaos going on
I can't even get a get a thought out
um okay we have uh we have cats and dogs
lying down together as they were last
week very happy
uh and we have mid-fall here in the
Pacific Northwest where it is gorgeous
and glorious and we encourage you until
we see you next time to be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]